businesses say as many as 90 of
candidates don't turn up to job
interviews and some quit soon after
being hired you're basically hiring
anyone that would show up paul horton
closes taco restaurant down in
mid-september after being left with just
two kitchen staff members horton said
he'd spend thousands of dollars
advertising
jobs at taco crush but that only around
10 percent of applicants replied after
he hired to arrange an interview of
those who scheduled interviews with only
5 percent and ten percent turned up you
can't be choosy anymore you're basically
hiring anyone that would show up some of
the businesses insider
spoke to added that some new hires
didn't turn up to their first shift or
that they quit after just a few weeks
why would you go work today if you got
money that's coming in why would you
even go want to put that effort in there
today by the way
this is this is a uh
uh interesting thing that i'm hearing
about a lot with businesses where
can you imagine like this goes back to
standard conversation you're like dude
you are so not qualified for this job
but dude just the fact that you're
sitting here you know what you're hired
i have no other choice good help is hard
to find just backward nakai bro that was
just just the fact that you showed up
that's definitely not kai because kai is
qualified but what do you what do you
think about when you hear a story like
this uh i don't think you're gonna like
what i have to say about this to be
honest with you man i think that that
quit your [ __ ] and compete you want
better employees pony up
what you
you you're you're not offering a
compensation package that's getting you
the type of employee that you want oh
nobody's gonna work today yeah i don't
know man do you think apple's having
trouble finding employees
do you think for a different job
do you think tesla's having trouble
finding it those are specialists go get
a job over there go go you go get a job
over there go get go get it no you go
get a job apple go get one go go get a
job i don't want a job at that point
i got a good job here
i hear your most recent comments you
might be looking to update your resume
buddy no no but the point then becomes
we already established i could be as
anti-semitic as i want nothing will
happen that's not true buddy we'll go oh
we'll get 30 lawyers here in about seven
seconds
first of all the comments he made in the
past he's done but we already know that
he comments he makes the call over
that's a different story you got you got
paul's work to work out by the way you
know they say that the lowest paying
employee at facebook is at like six
figures they showed it the other day the
lowest paid employee at facebook is at
six figures wow so no no no those i i
did a story on it it was 90 percent like
some employees are at six people
everyone's making six years however
there are people making you know fifty
thousand euros you know so but the
underwriting staff but what point is
this if you want that six-figure job go
learn coding and go apply i hear you go
for it but then then if you want to open
the taco bell knock off get yourself
some robots like what do you want
this guy has to do yeah then that taco
that's a buck 99 he's got to charge four
bucks for you okay with that hey listen
man are you okay with this okay what
happened
but are you okay with that anytime tacos
go up in price i am not okay all right
the lunch is the lunch is too damn high
any time
these rich people
i don't think i think that that's a guy
bitching for no reason he's not
attractive you know if you're not
attracting
talent that's a self-evaluation moment
talent to be to this
this is whole lowest of the lowest dude
i
i made whoppers at burger king okay you
know how much talent it required for me
to make those whopper no onion it didn't
take a lot of talent yeah i would put
the patties from the other side and i
would line them up three okay and they
would fall off my patties would always
break so if you ever had patties that
were broken a whopper i'm i'm a big pot
i couldn't get these guys
i would try to like put them pieces
together like i'm playing this puzzle
game and then they would say no onions i
would forget i would put onions and
you're like taking a bite there's onions
right and all this other stuff but
anyways that was my job yeah i didn't
need a four-year or two-year degree well
you should pay me more than whatever i
was making at the time maybe maybe
people feel like an hour of their life
is not worth seven dollars then guess
what you know you know you know what the
business owner has to do then this
whopper is not worth the buck 99 it's
worth 3.99 and you got to pay for it but
this is this is the market you know
there's this thing called capitalism i
hear you and the math because there's
only a hundred pennies in about hey the
capitalism i love capitalism but there's
land labor and capital three different
sides of course labor doesn't have to
always take it on the chin here they do
not and they do not take it on the chin
all the time labor if labor is telling
you i don't want to do your
job this is not a specialized position i
hear you but
what's so different so then what you're
suggesting is a 15 minimum wage maybe
what i'm suggesting is that this guy
yeah all right should go out of business
is what i'm suggesting if he can't
attract people all right and there's no
christ and he doesn't and he he doesn't
have the clientele no bro right do you
know what pain these
so first you're talking to a guy who
went out of business by the way you're
talking so you're talking to a guy
that's you
had to work hundreds of hours a week for
15 years to finally be able to have the
situation that you're in so i understand
the world of business and how it works
these restaurant guys margins they're
working on five percent what are you
talking about but so what pat if he is
having trouble all right attracting
employees
what is his suggestion as to what so so
let me ask you a question
but what i'm trying to tell you is this
is a basic math question and you're a
math guy okay so when you sit there and
you go through what the cost of your
patty is sure what the cost of the meat
is the lettuce the tomato oh it's all
going up which is all going up the cost
of real estate the cost of rent the cost
of electricity the cost of cleaning crew
the cost of the cost of i can go on cost
of insurance costs of workers comp cost
of everything sure this ain't cheap this
is a lot of cost and then all of that
nobody else cares about your business
more than you you have to work non-stop
you're there 24 7. seven days a week
you're missing practice you're missing
time with kids you're missing all that
stuff
and your margins at restaurants are five
percent how much is welfare
so if they apply for welfare whatever
government assistance yeah if they get
paid more with that than then yes they
will okay then so i don't know
yeah so my question is okay so you say
like uh only five percent to 10 showed
up maybe they're just going to these
businesses and saying no after they get
applied you know just to show like yeah
i tried six six months you got to be uh
employed for six months before you can
get on first of all or just show that
like you know like for for someone that
keeps
yeah they're like yeah you know i
applied
today guys don't even the lowest paying
workers don't even have to go to work
the math doesn't make it make any sense
but but the point is when a
sackey comes out and says if business
owners decide to raise prices because of
taxes that is a unhuman thing to do
whatever comments she made like four
weeks ago we talked about it she's got
an economist she is not an economist
neither is gerard but the point i'm
trying to make to use you got a five
percent mark the specific stories
restaurant you got a five percent margin
in this do you know why uh uh companies
like facebook or companies like these uh
software companies can pay what they pay
you know what their margins are what do
you think's a margin of these companies
don't say it i wanna hear what he says
what do you think their margins are
depends on the product but i mean their
margins are through the freaking i mean
look at apple apple doesn't develop a
[ __ ] game yeah they get and they're the
large system so how much does it take to
sustain the app
nothing you just have that platform
right they got 40
margins this guy's got a five percent
margin so it's a very different world
when you're talking about industries i
agree
last year we sat there and we looked at
all our employees i sat there and i said
i want every position that i'm looking
at and these 20 higher paid then we're
paying right now you know what happened
to the quality people we hired to the
roof but we could now afford it to get
people like that right
seven years ago we couldn't
five years ago we couldn't now we can
here we go we brought seven c-suite
executives new we went from two or three
to seven new c-suite executives that we
have with a bigger pay with better
bonuses with better equity because now
we can afford it this restaurant guy is
not a freaking rich guy that you think
this guy's broke
he's had a rough 18 months and he's
dealing with five percent margin i don't
think that he's rich but i think that
like he's not entitled to other people's
labor
he's got to compete for people's labor
and just because he opened up a taco
shop doesn't guarantee that he's going
to be successful nobody congratulations
guys nobody's saying this but you guys
are disputing math
you've got a five percent margin you're
dealing with so if i can't he knows that
going in yeah he knows that if things
maybe it's ten percent that's why but
things don't work
man guys you're sitting you're talking
as if these are restaurants tens of
thousands of restaurants you go to
these guys stop tomorrow and they say
they don't want to do this anymore to
serve you you ain't got a place to go
you got to figure out a way for these
guys to also survive now margins wise if
you're saying you got to pay more no
problem but you also have to agree that
they're going to have to raise prices
they're going to be raising prices so
you're okay with that i'm not okay with
it but i'm not you can't you can
inevitability you can't say pay
employees more but don't raise money
inevitability of inflation prices are
going up anyway why would somebody
you're going to have a you're going to
have uh oh i forget the term of it um
social stratification no that there's a
term there's a term for basically it's
like a disillusioned employee right so
like bread when bread is a dollar making
seven dollars fine i'll do it when bread
is five dollars make it seven dollars an
hour they're just like screwed it's not
even worth it
it's an hour of my life for a loaf of
bread i'm not gonna work then then if
you're okay with the guy raising prices
to meet his five to ten percent margin
then he should pay more you're asking
totally if i'm okay with inflation it's
if i'm not increased increasing
inflation no
you're saying to compete in a market
competing in the market is meaning i
have to go above and beyond inflation to
be able to hang with other people sure
that's two different things you're not
saying to you know raise it according to
inflation no because the guy across the
street from me that's a 50 billion
dollar fast food joint and a restaurant
i can't compete with that guy let me let
me ask you this one okay let me take
that go back to the same walmart than
the market across the street let me take
that same logic okay if i go up to that
guy and i say hey look your taco is four
dollars but i i only got three
it should only be three dollars that's
all i have i only make nine dollars an
hour i i can't spend half my money on
taco go elsewhere yeah those employees
are going elsewhere totally getting not
paying enough i get this they go
elsewhere this guy's it's two you know
how much money he's got elsewhere you
know how much he's got in the bank how
much do you think this guy's got in the
bank don't care maybe it's something
he's not entitled to being a businessman
he used to come up with a better
business i don't disagree with the part
that many people that are business
owners shouldn't be business owners i
don't disagree with that but the basics
of math works this way if you want me to
pay you more i have to make my margin
back in december sure you have to raise
prices if you're okay with raising
prices i'll pay you more and if he
raises prices and the market suggests
your product sucks bingo yeah that's
okay that's not a problem if you can't
get employees you have to do something
at that point but but you just went from
one angle thinking it's just a one-angle
story it's like a five-dimensional
conversation i think that the guy
probably just
look
my thing is this man nobody is entitled
to i'm not entitled to that man's tacos
he's not entitled to this man's labor do
you know how i'm not entitled to anybody
else do you know what percentage do you
know how many people work in a
restaurant business in america
pre-coping you know what that number is
i i would say 40 million high i would
bet it's pretty high 40 million people
yeah over 10 years you know how many of
them don't have a job you know how many
people in new york right now are getting
crushed because they don't have the cash
to survive you know how many people are
getting destroyed because they can't get
people to come back to work so they're
like dude i don't even know what to do
hey honey can you come and work with me
it's not because their product sucks the
climate sucks this is not the small
business owner's fault you just say
screw you get the hell out of here i'm
in the sales business right my sales
guys that go through certain things you
have to understand the challenges
they're facing at times when we first
had the code i'm like you suck here's
what you got i'm talking about it's not
how this thing works that's how
innovation works though pat is he
offering right what is he offering paid
days off what's he offering if he can't
offer more money what's he offering
people when you're small you don't have
a lot to offer that's why it's called
small business owner 49 of americans
work for a small business i love small
business owners this guy sounds like a
bad business it's not one guy though
well you're not talking about one guy
there's plenty of guys let me say
pat
whether this guy's got a good business
model or a bad business model it's
almost irrelevant it's the climate that
we're in what was it two-thirds of
people were getting paid more to stay
home during this pandemic than to go to
work so that's part of the climate
stimulus checks unemployment insurance
you talked about welfare
but let me say something if you're an
employee right now
we've talked about the great reset the
great resignation people are all right
does this do i even like this job maybe
we're seeing left and right
50 of the workforce is
thinking about changing jobs if you're
an employee right now you talked about
paying your staff twenty percent more i
assume that's at php
um
now's the time to go get your raise i
think uh if you're if you're um an
employee typically you get what a two to
three percent raise a year inflation you
know
cost of living adjustment all that now
with inflation that's going on right now
now you should be looking for at least
minimum five percent okay minimum but if
you're really good at what you do
you're you're talking about paying 20
more go get your money the time is now
as you know it usually the the
the um the powers in the business owner
right or in the small business hey we
create the wages you come work for us
now
for whatever reason call it the climate
calling the pandemic called everything
that's going on now's the time to go get
your money so if you're in between jobs
and you're not happy right now go get
your money and you'll you'll get what
the market pays you
yeah okay the the pain the pain of a
business owner if you're not one you're
not gonna know the pain of the business
owner if if you don't know the pain of
what a lot of these guys are going today
that are creating jobs for people you
have no clue what it is you know when
we'll hire people and i'll and i'll
judge people that work for a company
based on one basic thing
it's very easy to say you should give
that guy raise but it's not your money
it's very easy to say we should do this
more but it's not your money and the
guys that typically eventually end up
being leaders are the guys that manage
the money as if it's their own money
this small business owner's margins are
tiny you're throwing around stuff saying
well you don't deserve to do this yeah
say that to a hundred thousand
restaurants today in america they're
getting crushed so then the argument
becomes
that ubi is necessary for certain people
the argument becomes let's give some
money to certain people i'm not with
that buddy i talk to these guys and they
have probably more anxiety panic 18
months divorces challenges kids issues
than you would even know today because
of what happened last 18 months and now
you can't even get people to go to work
yeah that's uh that's what happens
when socialism shows up and you give
money away for free when you start doing
that workers don't show up so if you
enjoy this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]